more often than not horror sequels are
downgraded ripoffs of the original we're
out what may have been a novel concept
to begin with or resort to extreme Gore
and jump scares to one of their
predecessor sad to do that please please
by definition alone they're inferior
films that's true of most sequels really
but it seems especially common in this
genre there are exceptions to every rule
however and these sequels not only live
up to their horrifying predecessors
they're even better Evil Dead 2 without
the Evil Dead we would have never been
introduced to ash in his cabin of
Horrors so there's certainly something
to be said for the merits of the movie
that started at all
however the recall as Bruce Campbell
calls it was a lot campy er and more
self-aware and as a result more fun
instead of ash coming in as the
prototypical hero type he became a lot
more humorous and quirky sure this meant
the gore got dialed down a bit but it
also set a new tone for the series that
was much cheekier and far more unique
than the first evil ash groovy ash more
mania Evil Dead 2 cemented the series as
a viable franchise opening the door for
movie 3 army of Darkness as well as a
remake and the TV spin-off series
ash vs. Evil Dead Bruce Campbell may
have done other work in between all
these Evil Dead installments but he'll
still be forever known for his demonic
slaughtering skills ya lookin good
lookin sweet Friday the 13th Part 2 the
first Friday the 13th certainly set the
tone for what would become a sprawling
series of slasher picks targeting teen
counselors at Camp Crystal Lake
the counselors weren't paying any
attention they were making love while
that young boy dropped
his name was Jason but its commitment to
realism and having a villain who's a
real person rather than future franchise
mainstay Jason Voorhees meant it wasn't
really all that different from any other
entry in the team's running from psycho
killer sub-genre the second movie
however threw caution to the wind and
resurrected Jason from his watery grave
to do all the death feeling and it
totally paid off not only is Friday the
13th part to eerie and well made but the
idea that Jason would be the one to take
up his mother's torch and terrorize
campers for the next few decades was
solid and sustainable without this movie
Jason Voorhees wouldn't be such an icon
of the horror genre which is just plain
unimaginable the Devil's Rejects Rob
Zombie's House of a thousand corpses was
a shockingly brutal parade of violence
and mayhem and produce some pretty
unforgettable moments of violence that
will haunt many nightmares forever but
the Devil's Rejects came along and took
its trio of nefarious murderers into
more realistically terrifying territory
baby Otis and Captain Spaulding are seen
fleeing the police and tormenting anyone
unfortunate enough to find themselves in
their path you're not gonna kill us are
ya
killin sounds so permanent the Devil's
Rejects may have lost the atmospheric
creepiness of the original but it
somehow managed to be even more
disturbing since all these killings were
done in plain sight the depravity of
these three was downright horrifying and
the fact that the movie was so packed
with relatable victims made the dread
that much more visceral than its
predecessor
it's a better kid going to like crowns
saw to saw is a modern horror classic
that introduced audiences to a game no
one in their right mind would ever want
to play with special focus on the two
victims of the day saw presented jigsaw
in his philosophical death-dealing
scheme and paid off with the twist
ending that opened the dirty bathroom
door to a whole franchise of gory traps
[Music]
but where the first movie suffered from
pacing issues due to its shoestring
budget and tight set space the second
movie cleverly expanded the jigsaw
universe there will be blood not only
did it present the film's first survivor
Amanda as jigsaws protege but it also
committed to its puzzle dynamic and got
even more creative with its terrifying
traps let the game begin saw to was more
exciting and interactive with the
audience and it offered much more
insight into who jigsaw was and what he
wanted to accomplish by creating a
legacy
by living a life worth remembering you
become immortal with the added layer of
a bigger game and play for one of the
detectives investigating jigsaws crimes
saw to began to really flesh out the
formula introduced by the first and
offered a sustainable launch pad for the
bevy of sequels to follow game over Wes
Craven's new nightmare a nightmare on
elm street Cyrill concept that a
boogeyman who haunted dreams could
actually kill a person in their sleep
was enough to make anyone afraid of
bedtime but once that storyline was
beaten to death with a slew of
progressively lame sequels franchise
mastermind Wes Craven decided to get a
little more creative about how to amp up
the entry with Wes Craven's new
nightmare he ventured outside of the box
and pegged all the predecessors as the
fictional movies that they were my
nightmares I'm dreaming them in order
for the movie to continue it was
dependent on be having more nightmares
well fortunately I did once his killer
creation Freddy Krueger started bleeding
into real life though his original stars
had to play their old parts in an effort
to stop the very evil he'd created with
the original series what resulted was a
smart statement about the industry and
his own place in it and a film that was
both self-aware and completely
entertaining at the same time
[Music]
scream - scream remains a central piece
of 90s slasher history thanks to its
portable killer and fascination with its
own genre like scary and its sequel
scream - took the property to new
heights by focusing on what made the
original so well original the first
installment followed a fairly standard
formula about a masked killer offing
high-school students but there was an
element of satisfying self-awareness
that set the movie apart scream -
accentuated that aspect by introducing a
movie within a movie storyline that
winked at its own pop cultural relevance
in the charming new way while some of
the kill scenes from the first film were
a little more thrilling than anything
that came after the first sequel subtle
statements about itself were
refreshingly on point the purge Anarchy
the purge was laser focused on a single
family trying to survive America's
annual night of government sanctioned
murder and mayhem
he's just purged and while that was
exciting enough to spawn a sequel there
was a lot of room to grow once the
concept proved to be viable at the box
office instead of just focusing again on
a select few struggling to survive the
night the purge Anarchy introduced some
of the socio-economic factors that would
be an important part in creating such a
system of disorder while fans of the
first film might have been left to
wonder why and how the u.s. stoop to
allowing such chaos Anarchy attempted to
answer those questions by putting its
central players outside the comfort of
their own homes we got to see a lot more
of the destruction and fallout from the
purge and it was a lot more satisfying
and informative can't have heroes the
parallels to the Occupy movement also
set the stage for the third installment
the purge election year and the pic also
left room for the forthcoming prequel
series that we'll delve into how society
devolved in the first place Dawn of the
Dead George a Romero's Night of the
Living Dead is a classic no doubt about
it
it marked the beginning of the zombie
film craze and holds up as an esteemed
chapter in his filmography that coming
to get you Barbra
however Dawn of the Dead the second
installment in his
Living Dead series expanded the first
movies ideas by showcasing the proof
cause of this epidemic when there's no
more room in hell the film more narrowly
pinpointed Romero's parallels between
zombification and American consumerism
by having its victims take cover in a
shopping mall and the film's
juxtaposition of excess and materialism
with hopelessness and violence help
define the zombie genre as a whole
forever the Texas Chainsaw Massacre at
the beginning when it comes to the Texas
Chain Saw series nothing has or probably
ever will beat tobe Hooper's 1974
original when it comes to the modern
reboots though there are some which were
better than the others after a series of
Texas Chain Saw sequels that got
progressively more ludicrous 2003 s
reboot looked to return the franchise to
its original form by having a group of
unexpected teams return to leather faces
isolated abode the pick benefited from
modern cinematography and sound effects
and one deliciously evil sheriff that
made Leatherface seem like a teddy bear
however it added very little to the
story we already knew its sequel the
beginning however did some digging as to
why this cannibalistic family became
what they were the way their backstory
developed was clever and included some
of the franchise's best dialogue no
talking until actor have said great more
importantly the plot also paid more
attention to its societal environment
namely the Vietnam War in the
Conscription that played two generations
youth dead okay it still didn't
transcend the original by any stretch of
the imagination but it certainly bested
the previous sequels and reboots in the
series thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]